yeah welcome to a new game here against
Megatron mmhmm yeah let's go for the
name zone test some of my repertoire
suggestions
I mean repertoire suggestions means the
stuff that I'm investigating for the
opening book
yeah funny funny a way to to transpose
him and that's a transposition but the
transformation of the position black can
switch to a dark square strategy here
with five and white in the meantime
plate moves like night a4 and a3 which
are locked which are not especially
useful
hmm
ok
it's not exactly ambitious let's go here
you place before I can take on before
Bishop before quite quite funny move
they want to play a 95 let's let's go
let's go for that shouldn't shouldn't be
bad our mentor secure this piece for a
moment
hmm maybe you should be for all was
interesting know that I think of it but
here maybe maybe f3m some good answer
okay so how to how to continue many
ideas what is he doing maybe Bishop 32
and beer before I'd like to play age
maybe I can play h5 instantly yeah why
not why not it's interesting the ideas
I'd like to give this check on d3 to
irritate them so maybe you cannot take
well with this I thought I take a play
Queen g5 and I'm very good but probably
I'm not he's got the bishop f3 of ok and
but happy for no no I happy for Bishop
e3 I have you form a form Knight takes
Knight takes Bishop takes Queen e5 eyes
got Bishop h7 check back this is aa aa
this was a check King age eight we
should be too hmm ah should be too okay
it's no no way back here anyway Knight
takes Knight takes Bishop takes Queen e5
and then he's got this check and Bishop
e2 where the sorcerer I thought this is
otherwise i'm just-just winning but
that's it doesn't seem to work hmm
I do it anyway it's odd to how to turn
back now
yeah at least he's got to have this
Bishop on a funny place
I don't know maybe yeah yeah well this
was entirely unnecessary the second two
points yeah I was simply at a
comfortable position it's not clear if
this was was was super grade or whatever
but Dwight had absolutely nothing and
then I went to went for this okay but
with with moves like castles he may be
gets me back in the game okay let's
let's play this first ship f3 maybe was
was better I don't know Bishop f3 I need
to get to the king
so I would take it it's not it's not
enough probably came I need you prepared
i also have Bishop c5 know how many
years completely destroyed his structure
with f3 and h3 I mean he needed to do it
after castles which was really bad and
now it's not even clear here in this
position got me three hanging Bishop c5
is coming the shop c 50 bishop g 3
episode 33 is also not bad just try to
to get a look here and the game brooke
age six and take on age three just what
I be should be one now
k
yeah I need to break through now I don't
have much time and it's a not sure if it
is so it's in any way working and
probably not them but don't
no threatening Luke age 60
Luke age six and I'm d3 is still hanging
time morning
unbelievable
Jeff
check-check
yeah okay they've got the no time at all
black forfeits on time yeah yeah yeah
this was a bit much I mean our queen g6
and black wins I am I completely brain
dead or what today Queen g six wins
apiece of course yeah 26 and it's it's
over whenever but we needed he really
played this very very badly and moving
moving out stuff twice and three times
and four times and it must men must have
some consequence but I just I'm just too
stupid myself okay so this is what's my
initial idea this is two points down and
now we cancel it which is just bad i
mean why why castle into this attack
it's probably okay mathematically but
why would you do that ok now let's let's
continue a couple of moves until I'm
probably better again maybe I'm not what
a game as I thought I had something but
maybe yeah okay this all defense yeah
okay I had had nothing and now it still
felt like and let's hear you can do
something but Queen g6 was positive
though that this is really stupid Queen
g6 so h5 was right yeah I really like
this idea h5 it's even the computer move
really good if you find such resources
it's it's strong I mean this is the big
threat end
yeah it's a shame this is really strong
I mean and now I simply figured failed I
mean I played all this because I wanted
to take and 25 but it's got the silly
check on age 7 and it still I should
have taken a bit of time here and Queen
g6 is not not difficult i mean ah ok